Mō tātou, a, mō ka uri a muri ake nei
The Waimakariri District Council has recently
reached a lease agreement with Land Information New Zealand
for much of the Regeneration area land.
This is great news for our community as we can get underway with priority regeneration projects
while we wait for full land divestment to be completed.
After hearing back from the local community,
Council has approved option two, which will
see Cass Street closed at the entrance to
the sports and recreation reserve
and Jollie Street reinstated.
The rebuild of Courtenay Drive has been delayed
by the discovery of asbestos
in the land underneath the existing road.
Specialists have been appointed to deal with the situation
and construction of the new road will start in January.
Work has also begun in the Kaiapoi Food Forest.
Fruit trees from red-zoned properties have
been relocated
and a public planting day recently took place.
We’ll have lot more on this in our next
update.
Many of the facilities proposed for the Regeneration
Areas are going to be great for local youth
and today we’re going find out how they’ve been involved in process so far
and what they're excited about.
I'm Emma and we're KYDZ, which stands for Kaiapoi Youth Division
We are all from different schools and we help Kaiapoi be better with our youth.
We are excited for the Regeneration for Kaiapoi
I remember a lot of people, even though we already have McDonald's and fish and chips,
a lot of people put a lot of takeaways down.
Most kids just hand around at the library these days,
so it would be better to actually have somewhere where we could go.
Maybe around there, there could be some benches, like bleachers.
So, if we have a half-court game and our parents want to come along
then they can sit on the bleachers and watch us.
Instead of having to use all our petrol and parent's stuff to take us into town,
they could, for once ,come out to us and play us.
Where you can go and pick your own fruit, the trees,
it would be good to have a few more of them around.
I think it will be good, but we need some more stuff to do with shopping
and other things besides sports.
New spaces to shop and eat was a popular request amongst our youth.
A year ago, Halle Pitama presented ideas from
Tuahiwi School to the Hearing Panel of what
they wanted in the Recovery Plan.
I talked about things that I'd like to see in the area.
Like retail, businesses, more sports fields,
recreation centre - inside and outside.
The whole food forest thing happening over here is great
because it makes me think about my family's history
of not just having to go to New World to get food
that you can come here and I can do something during the weekend, like
support this whole thing going on and help out, just for the community to
come back and just something to do.
We also talked to the Waimakariri
Youth Council on progress at their September meeting
and they were really keen to be involved.
Our next update will be all about the Kaiapoi
Food Forest.
This is a really popular community-led project, and a lot of work has already been done.
And with the roading options confirmed, we’ll look at the updated layout
for the sports and recreation reserve.